ASSUMPTION STATE.
HE PROMISED US ON THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO DELAWARE.
HERE WITH MORE, FLORIDA
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO.
A SENATOR, NOT ONLY JOE BIDEN'S
POLICIES, BUT THEY ARE ALSO
INVOLVED IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING
BECAUSE THEY ARE LITERALLY
TRANSPORTING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
INTO EVERY STATE AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
AND THEN JUST LEADING THEM THERE
AND THEN IT BECOMES THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATE TO
PROVIDE FOOD, WATER, SHELTER,
MEDICAL TREATMENT, HEALTH CARE,
AND EDUCATION.
MOST STATES CAN'T AFFORD IT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE -- THAT
IS THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
THERE IS THIS PELOSI PUPPET,
THIS CONGRESSWOMAN THAT
CHUCK SCHUMER HANDPICKED TO RUN
AGAINST ME.
SHE IS IN FAVOR TO COMPLETELY
OPEN BORDERS.
NOT ABORTING PEOPLE EVEN IF THEY
ARE GANG MEMBERS.
AS A RESULT OF THESE STANCES,
THIS IS THE SPEAKER THAT HE IS
ON JUST A MOMENT AGO AND TALKS
ABOUT HOW THIS IS ABOUT VALUES,
PRINCIPLES, AND THEY ARE WACKY.
THESE ARE RADICAL IDEAS.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING COME OF THE
IMAGES YOU ARE SEEING IS JUST
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG OF THE
KIND OF AGENDA OF THESE PEOPLE
WANT TO FOLLOW.
NO COUNTRY IN THE WORLD WOULD
ALLOW THE LAWLESSNESS THAT WE
HAVE.
>> WE JUST TALKED WITH
NEWT GINGRICH ABOUT THE BORDER
DISASTER, THE AFGHANISTAN
WITHDRAWAL DISASTER, THE LACK OF
URGENCY IN UKRAINE, THE ECONOMY,
THE 40 YEAR HIGH INFLATION.
WHOLESALE PRICES SETTING A NEW
RECORD, 40 IRAQ RATE OF
INFLATION.
ENERGY NOW DOUBLE WHAT IT WAS
UNDER DONALD TRUMP WHEN
JOE BIDEN INHERITED ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
CRIME IS OUT OF CONTROL.
IT JOE BIDEN EVEN RAN OUT OF
COVID TESTS AROUND CHRISTMAS
GOING INTO THE THIRD YEAR OF A
PANDEMIC.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN DO ANY
WORSE THAN THAT.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT MAJOR ISSUES
IN FRONT OF THIS COUNTRY,
EVERYTHING IS WORSE THAN IT WAS
WHEN JOE BIDEN TOOK OVER.
AND FRANKLY THAT IS WHY NEW
PEOPLE SO.
I'M ASKING THEM TO GO TO MARCO
RUBIO.COM BECAUSE I'M BEING
OUTRAISED -- THIS MOVEMENT FROM
THE LEFT KNOW THAT THEY CAN'T
WIN THE ELECTION.
OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE A LOT OF
HELP FROM THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
ANY PEOPLES HELP TO FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THIS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO HEAR THAT STORY.
THEY DON'T WANT PEOPLE HERE IN
THE REALITY ON EVERY ISSUE, OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY, WE ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY WORSE OFF TODAY
THAN WE WERE JANUARY OF LAST
YEAR WHEN JOE BIDEN TOOK OVER ON
EVERYTHING.
THE ONE YOUR ELECTION IS
CRITICAL.
THIS IS A BELLWETHER ELECTION
YEAR BECAUSE IT IS FLORIDA FOR
THE SENATE, I'M TALKING ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY.
IT IS GEORGIA, NORTH AND
SOUTH CAROLINA, NEW HAMPSHIRE,
PENNSYLVANIA, MISSOURI, OHIO.
IT IS WISCONSIN, IT IS NEVADA,
IT IS ARIZONA.
IT DOESN'T GET ANY MORE
BELLWETHER AND IT IS ALASKA
HOPEFULLY KELLY TSHIBAKA CAN WIN
UP THERE.
IT DOESN'T GET ANY MORE
BELLWETHER CENTER.
YOUR ELECTION IS CRITICAL.
>> FLORIDA HAS A SPECIAL PLACE
IN THEIR HEART.
OUR STATE LEGISLATURE.
I THINK IS A SPECIAL PLACE IN
THEIR HEART, THEY REALLY, REALLY
WANT TO WIN THESE RACES IN
FLORIDA.
I'M JUST ASKING EVERYONE TO GO
TO MARCO RUBIO.COM BECAUSE I
NEED YOUR HELP.
IT IS A BELLWETHER STAGE.
THEY'VE EMBARRASSED THE
PERFORMANCE OF BLUE STATES AND
BLUE CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE DESPERATE TO WIN SOME
RACES HERE IN FLORIDA AND THEY
ARE POURING A